Sometimes you can tell if two animals are
related just by looking at them.
It’s no surprise dogs and wolves share a
common ancestor.
Or that tree squirrels and chipmunks are in
the same family.
But occasionally, two different species share
a relation which stretches the mind.
So, for this entry into the archive, let’s
take a look at the animals you’d never guess
would show up to the same family reunion.
To start off, we have rhinos and horses.
Just looking at the multi-ton, leathery rhino,
you might sooner guess it’s a cousin of
the elephant or hippopotamus.
How is this possible?
Well, while the exact common ancestor of these
two has yet to be found, we know both rhinos
and horses are distantly related to the same
small forest dwelling predecessor called Hyracotherium.
The genus lived during the Eocene period.
I’ve got more on them and other tiny early
mammals in another video.
Today, the hulking rhino and majestic horses
have clearly gone in different adaptational
directions.
Despite this, both species still belong to
the same larger category: the odd toed ungulates:
a classification which also includes the tapir.
That’s right — there’s a third branch
in this family tree.
The tapir is a squat, somewhat odd-looking
herbivore with a short trunk like and elephant
for grasping at food — despite also having
little relation to actual elephants.
Looking at these three side-by-side, they
hardly look similar, but that’s the funny
thing about adaptation.
Up next, we have seals and bears.
The cuddly aquatic seal might appear far off
from the large, terrestrial bear.
But genetically speaking, the two mammal groups
are pretty closely related.
It’s believed both animals share a common
ancestor in the Pujila — an extinct species
of semi-aquatic mammal.
Over the course of millions of years, some
members of this ancestral species spent more
and more time in the water: and became the
almost fully aquatic group we recognize as
seals today.
Other remained mostly on land and became larger,
heavier, and more diverse until they developed
into the various modern bear species we’re
now familiar with.
But biologically speaking, the two are still
cousins.
Continuing on, we have the hippopotamus and
the dolphin.
The four limbed, heavy-set hippo and the sleek,
flippered dolphin might seem like total opposites
at first glance.
But like many of the other pairs on this list,
they share a common ancestor.
The two groups split off around 60 million
years ago.
And the group that eventually gave us the
dolphin: the cetaceans, also includes all
species of porpoises and whales.
Meaning the whale and hippopotamus are, incredibly,
also related.
What a curious lineage.
Next, we’ve got the elephant: which, as
we’ve already established, isn’t as closely
related to other African Megafauna like rhinos
or hippos as you might expect.
So, what are the closest living relatives
of the largest land animal on planet earth?
The rock hyrax— a species of tiny, rodent
like mammals.
And the manatee.
At the very least, manatees are a hefty, leathery
group of animals — so you can somewhat see
how such a species might be related to the
elephant.
But the tiny, furry rock hyrax seems like
quite the odd relative to the heaviest thing
on the African savanna.
Part of how we know these two species are
related is the makeup of the Hyrax’s front
teeth is actually similar to that of an elephant’s
tusks.
Indeed, the two species only diverged around
65 million years ago, which isn’t that impossibly
long on an evolutionary timescale.
Pretty interesting.
Moving on, we have the echidna and the platypus.
While these two don’t look ‘alike,’
they are perhaps the most made up-seeming
organisms alive today.
So, it kind of tracks they’d be related.
Both groups are the only mammals currently
living which lay eggs.
Even stranger, however, the platypus is able
to detect electric fields with its bill — and
have venomous elbows.
Like the platypus, the echidna can also detect
electric fields in its bill through its snout,
which is part of links the two mammals to
each other.
What an incredible pair.
Nearing the end, we have the giraffe and the
pronghorn antelope.
Giraffes are such unique mammals in general,
with their extremely long necks and characteristic
spots, that you might not assume anything
— let alone an antelope would be their relatives.
And indeed, despite their name, pronghorn
antelopes aren’t actually antelopes at all
— but an offshoot species more closely linked
to the giraffe.
This relation is a relatively recent scientific
discover — and frankly, it’s almost nice
to know the truly unusual giraffes have a
genetic relative.
They might still stick out as the tallest
living terrestrial animal, but as it turns
out, they’re not alone, biologically speaking.
Finally, we have jellyfish and coral.
Since jellyfish are free-floating, ethereal
animals, and coral are so sedentary they hardly
seem like animals at all, you’d be forgiven
for assuming they have nothing in common.
But in fact, both jellyfish and coral are
cnidarians: aquatic animals with specialized
cells for capturing prey.
You might not think of coral as hunting prey
at all, but in fact, some species do possess
stinging tentacles like jellyfish, which they
use to ensnare floating zooplankton that gets
too close.
Indeed, some coral have even been observed
consuming jellyfish — which seems quite
surprising.
And that’s the end of our analysis of animals
you might not have known were related.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support, and like, subscribe, and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on all
things Curious.
See you in the next video.